bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour cette nouvelle édition de
votre journal quotidien les titres de ce
jeudi à 25 juin 2015 les taxis en guerre
contre les vtc et l'application humber
des manifestations parfois violentes
dans la capitale et principale ville de
france mobilisation aussi sur les
yvelines à versailles avec des
rassemblements devant la préfecture
première instance de ce type en france
le conseil des institutions musulmanes
des yvelines vient d'être lancée il doit
permettre réflexion et médiation afin
d'apporter des solutions invités pour en
parler mohamed oufkir ou bi président de
l'association des musulmans des yvelines
et puis dernier volet de notre dossier
consacré à l'europe avec ce soir le
dispositif back to school ils permettent
à des membres du personnel des
institutions européennes de s'inviter le
temps d'une journée dans leur ancienne
école pourrait parler de leur métier
aujourd'hui les taxis étaient donc dans
la rue dans de nombreuses villes de
france des opérations escargot mais
aussi des blocages aux abords des
aéroports notamment pour manifester leur
mécontentement face à la concurrence
qu'ils jugent déloyale de ce nouveau
service
humber poc certains dérapages à noter
des scènes de violences également du
côté des yvelines deux cortèges se sont
élancés jusqu'à la préfecture de
versailles pour faire valoir leurs
différentes revendications et elles ont
été entendues
williams elle pour ce reportage
le service de vtc humber pop est
désormais interdit dans les yvelines
ce matin les voyants des taxis étaient
au rouge à l'arrêt complet à versailles
devant la préfecture
au coeur du problème la demande d'un
arrêté départemental interdisant
l'application une demande soutenue par
le préfet des yvelines
l'année dernière quand on ouvre l
application on voyait quasiment pas
d'hubert pop sur la périphérie de
versailles on va dire dans moins d'un an
ça a commencé autour de versailles
aujourd'hui vous ouvrez l'application un
soir aux heures de pointe dans la soirée
s'est remplie d'hubert porte que
rambouillet à versailles le long de la
nationale 10 par exemple je prends un
axe par exemple dans les grands axes
mais non aujourd'hui hubert prop est
très présent sur la banlieue
power pop dans le viseur des taxis
l'application qui propose les services
de chauffeur particulier se développe de
plus en plus dans le département
obligeant le taxi à partager le marché
avec cette nouvelle concurrence
maintenant on a d'autres revendications
qui elles sont plus d'une portée
nationale qui la concerne le vtc au sens
large
une révision de la loi pour qu'on arrive
à un équilibre ce qui est pas le cas
aujourd'hui la loi elle est bafouée
il est complètement déséquilibrée par
les actions en justice la deuxième chose
c'est sur l'acte de la formation est-ce
qu'on a un problème d'accès à la
profession ce qui est un peu gênant dans
un moment où l'emploi est difficile on
est arrivé en quelques années de quatre
sessions d'examen par an à une ce qui ne
permet pas le renouvellement de la
profession ce qui implique des délais
assez longs pour accéder dans le métier
aujourd'hui en moyenne on est on va dire
sur une moyenne de deux années entre le
moment on se décide et le moment où on
accède éventuellement métier ce qui
décourage beaucoup de vocations
ce matin plus de 200 taxis étaient
présents préfecture après avoir obtenu
satisfaction sur la demande d'arrêter
interdisent en application les taxis ont
rejoint autorise à crise pour soutenir
le mouvement national cette annonce à
présent du conseil départemental des
yvelines les villes qui ont bénéficié
pour les inciter à construire des
logements bénéficié de primes vont
devoir rendre des comptes elles sont une
quinzaine à être dans le collimateur
pour ne pas avoir développé suffisamment
leur offre résidentielle trappe par
exemple va devoir rembourser 215 milles
euros sur les 7 millions qui ont été
octroyées par le conseil départemental
les plans de déplacement
inter-entreprises fait cette année à
leurs cinq ans l'occasion de tirer le
bilan de ses premières années pour la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi la cci de
versailles yvelines et les entreprises
partenaires ainsi que les différents
acteurs de ce dispositif pour fluidifier
les déplacements domicile travail toutes
les précisions mélanie poquet incité les
salariés des grandes entreprises à
délaisser leur voiture au profit
d'autres modes de transport
c'est le but des ppe les plans de
déplacement interentreprises
ils ont été mis en place en 2009 par la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la cci
versailles yvelines et les entreprises
volontaires
on a des premiers résultats qui sont
intéressant ça progresse c'est positif
mais ça progresse pas assez vite
15 % de nos salariés et que les
transports en commun avec une
amélioration de 0 5% par an avant de
passer à 20% il ya quelques années ces
dix ans donc on voudrait y arriver
plutôt en 2020 que en 2025
et si on peut le faire plus tôt c'est
encore mieux aujourd'hui 39 entreprises
font partie du dispositif sur saint
quentin en yvelines avec les secteurs
trappe elancourt le technocentre mes
rentes et soul sangliers puis salou clé
saint-pierre et le secteur centre dont
une aiguille en cours
cinquante mille personnes en bénéficient
pour renforcer les yeux ce sont
les habitudes qu'il faut avant tout
changer ils sont dans un réflexe voiture
donc qui se posent pas forcément la
question de faire autrement
non pas forcément la connaissance de
l'existence de toutes les alternatives
qui s'offrent à eux
il peut y avoir aussi des conditions qui
facilite cet usage là si par exemple ils
sont du stationnement facilement sur le
lieu de travail ça va forcément facilité
le visage de la voiture
chaque entreprise peut choisir son mode
de déplacement hilti basée à magny les
hameaux a choisi le covoiturage grâce à
une application lancée par une start up
parisienne
le crédit agricole dont les bureaux sont
à guyancourt favorise les modes doux et
notamment le vélo à assistance
électrique
les 2500 employés bénéficient
aujourd'hui d'une flotte de 10 vélos
nous on privilégie essentiellement
l'offre de bus de proposer par la casse
qui on veut pas de mettre deux navettes
propre parce que justement on n'a pas la
capacité non plus de fournir le nombre
d'usagers
dont on a besoin qui peut permettre de
rentabiliser une offre de navettes
salariés viennent d'un peu partout sont
passés mobile donc on privilégier au
maximum le travail avec la communauté
d'agglomération et par-delà avec le stif
pour développer facilité de les
transports collectifs existants sur les
3000 employés que compte le site airbus
dans la zone clé saint-pierre 15%
bénéficier des améliorations apportées
sur plusieurs lignes de bus dont trois
principales d'autres projets sont en
cours de réflexion pour réduire les
heures de transport ou favoriser le
rapprochement habitat travail pour les
cinq années à venir les différents
acteurs souhaitent accélérer les effets
pour 2015 maurepas est la seule ville du
département à intégrer la politique de
la ville les documents ont été signés
officiellement hier en mairie l'objectif
de ce contrat réduire les inégalités
économiques et sociales entre les
différents territoires de la commune
pour cela des aides financières vont
être débloqués
tous les ans le reportage est signée
michael et demi d'euros et le diwan
c'est officiel moore pas vient
d'intégrer la politique de la ville lé
document a été signé ce mercredi en
présence de grégory carré astier le
maire de la commune et du préfet des
yvelines
ce contrat vise à revaloriser certains
secteurs en difficulté et réduire les
inégalités sociales entre territoires
pour maurepas l'état a ciblé le quartier
des friches et ses mille six cent trente
habitants on a fait un quart voyage
national avec déclarée de m 200 m 200 m
et il fallait qu'il y ait plus de 1000
habitants dans ce carré avec revenu
médian qui sont inférieures aux moyennes
nationales ce qui est le cas du côté des
friches ici sur mon repas et donc il a
été sélectionné comme étant quartiers de
la politique de la ville au total trente
mille euros vont être débloqués cette
année par l'état pour aider le quartier
d'autres appuis financiers seront
distribués jusqu'en 2020 alors les 30000
euros sont répartis sur les trois
piliers fondamentaux du contrat de ville
que sont donc la cohésion sociale le
cadre de vie et le développement
économique et donc à l'intérieur de ce
contrat de ville que vous avez un
ensemble d'actions notamment pour
l'éducation c'est la mise en place d'un
projet éducatif et d'un plan éducatif
pour les élèves qui sont en difficulté
scolaire
et puis aussi sur l'emploi
nous allons créer des soirées
entreprises donc avec les habitants qui
cherchent un travail est en relation et
en partenariat aussi avec le pôle emploi
par exemple le travail c'est s'émanciper
et permettra également d'avoir une
meilleure vie le contrat a été signé
pour une durée de six ans il est ensuite
renouvelables mais l'objectif de la
mairie et de redresser le quartier le
plus rapidement possible pour le faire
sortir de la politique de la ville la
volonté c'est de dd au travers d'un
dispositif et d'action spécifique de
faire sortir ce quartier de la politique
de la ville à ce que la politique de la
ville allait là que pour aider
ponctuellement finalement un quartier et
l'idée comme les lieux rappelé tout à
l'heure le préfet dans son discours ce
n'est pas de pérenniser dans le temps
mais de faire sortir justement ce
quartier pour qu'ils soient finalement
comme comme les autres maurepas est la
seule commune diw n'entrant en 2015 dans
le cadre de la politique de la ville
invitée à présent de ce journal mohamed
ould boubi bienvenue sur ce plateau
je vais donc l'association des musulmans
de versailles accompagné de salix al
bonjour vous êtes le président de
l'association des musulmans de
saint-germain-en-laye on va revenir avec
vous sur la création du conseil des
institutions musulmanes dans les
yvelines c'est une première en france a
lancé la semaine dernière en présence du
préfet car c'est une instance de
dialogue entre l'état et les
représentants du culte musulman je le
disais c'est une première ça va servir à
quoi ça va servir quoi le 6 me répond à
un besoin
un besoin qui au fur et à mesure du
temps s'est vu propulsé au stade de
devoir pour des raisons très diverses
naturellement à les besoins de la
communauté musulmane mais aussi les
besoins des citoyens musulmans de se
sentir pleinement site web donc dans
cette dynamique là bien le simi va
s'employer à travers une vision qu'il va
distiller à satisfaire à ses besoins ça
veut dire que l'on a visité quelque part
de tous les côtés au soleil exposait les
besoins de
des citoyens musulmans il ya des gens
qui pensent que la france pourrait mieux
vivre aussi
il y avait des instances qui comme le
simi pouvait s'activer pour permettre
justement à la question du lien social
et du vivre ensemble de mieux s'épanouir
vous en attendez quoi vous par exemple
concrètement président d'une association
représentative de musulmans il y a aussi
toutes les problématiques aujourd'hui
que les structures 18 rue musulmanes
vivent au quotidien les problèmes de
salles de prière ou de mosquées je
dirais donc plus généralement également
les problèmes de du culte je n'en a
parlé de l'aïd el kébir le mois de
ramadhan avec les problèmes des espaces
pour pouvoir faire les prières nocturnes
voilà donc le signifier le dialogue avec
les élus par exemple c'est ce que nous
espérons parce que dans cette dans le
dialogue qui est qui est proposée il ya
effectivement l'état via la préfecture
il ya donc l'union des maires des
yvelines
donc qui est vraiment donc son acteur
pleinement au niveau local et donc il ya
aussi éventuellement des les autres
cultes 1 ça soit les chrétiens ou les
juifs dont qu'on permette vraiment
d'ouvrir le débat de façon générale et
d'essayer de trouver des solutions on va
dire pour l'ensemble des acteurs et en
particulier la communauté musulmane
je vous poser clairement la question est
ce que là avec cette démarche on est
aussi dans une volonté de transparence
de rassurer aussi les non musulmans
cette fois-ci vous disiez il ya
plusieurs raisons pour la création de ce
conseil les événements du début de
l'année les attentats charles et le dos
par exemple en font partie est-ce que ça
on est aussi dans cette démarche là la
transparence la visibilité mais pour
être plus concret il a mis jeudi
en commun de une volonté de mutualiser
des compétences pour permettre à tout un
chacun de mieux s'approprier un problème
et chacun ne sont partenaires de ce
dispositif
donc ça veut dire dans cet exercice dans
cette dynamique
étant donné que nous sommes dans une
instance de dialogue à l'endroit des
autorités à l'endroit d'abord de la
communauté musulmane parce qu'on a
besoin de tous ses remontées et de
revisiter les problèmes et de poser les
problématiques peut-être un peu
autrement de manière à ce que ça puisse
trouver dix ans ça puisse cheminer vers
une solution à travers d'abord comme je
les dis la communauté musulmane et bien
sûr les différents partenaires l'état
comme mais ces salles il vient de
préciser les différents maires ça dépend
du problème chaque problème à sa
caractéristique d'accord donc il nous
faut si on va utiliser un langage
scientifique et essayer communément
ensemble d' établir l'équation d'état
pour pouvoir voir comment de manière
apaisée nous pouvons apporter des
solutions à des problèmes qui
aujourd'hui crée du mal vivre dans la
société notamment à l'endroit de la
communauté musulmane et du citoyen
musulman
donc tout cela c'est quelque chose qui
est grand qu'ils aient titanus mais une
fille nous fait pas peur à partir du
moment où toutes les bonnes volontés
accepte de s'associer à ce projet nous
allons voir plus en détail comment cela
fonctionne on va juste faire une petite
pause avec notre micro-trottoir notre
question du jour ce conseil des
institutions musulmanes est ce une bonne
idée tout simplement qu'en pensez vous
je pense que c'est une très bonne idée
ça que je suis pas très au clair par
rapport au dialogue sur les musulmans et
les la communauté française mais je
pense que c'est une bonne idée pour
amener un peu de cohésion sociale
c'est une excellente chose tout ce qui
peut favoriser le dialogue je suis
absolument pour c'est quelque chose de
très important d assez par seulement
communauté entre communautés noires ou
communauté blanche mais aussi c'est
entre toutes les communautés toutes
confessions confondues toute religion ou
le présenta sociales confondues donc ça
permet aussi de réduire certaines
de conflit ou bien des préjugés ou
suivent amuser nous semble que je
connais pas de vraiment mais seulement
si c'est bien pour moi c'est un plus ça
me paraît évident que tout le monde doit
avoir droit à la parole
après
il faut que ce soit pour tout le monde
enfin accès possible pour tout le monde
pour toutes les religions en faudrait 10
a en fait c'est pas uniquement pour les
populations musulmanes
est ce que c'est vrai que ça peut
engendrer une stigmatisation je vous
fait réagir par rapport la
stigmatisation juste une petite
précision par rapport au micro trottoir
on peut très bien être musulman et
français ce n'est pas une nationalité
musulmans c'est juste une petite
remarque pour être bien clair sur cette
stigmatisation justement la création de
ce conseil spécifique aux musulmans il
faudra la même chose pour les autres
religions
je pense que pour la religion chrétienne
a déjà acheminé les on va dire vous avez
pas une peur de stigmatisation nouvelle
fois en créant un conseil spécifique
je pense pas que ça serve à ça puisque
ça d'abord ça a été saluée par
l'ensemble des communautés qui les
présentent le jour de l'installation
d'une part d'autre part nous émergeant
d'un secteur de d'expérience qui sont
multiples et diverses et je suis
moi-même vice-président du groupe
interreligieux pour la paix
donc je mesure à partir de ce
référentiel là ce besoin est on est loin
on comptait on est là pour éviter
justement cette stigmatisation
puisqu'une gagnon en proximité et nous
l'esprit fraternel qui habite par
exemple le groupe interreligieux pour la
paix on sent une certaine fraternité des
gens sont à l'aise et puis on ne regarde
plus tôt le problème en tant que
problème et nous essayons en
consultation et en nous enrichissant des
uns les autres d'apporter les
éclaircissements il faut justement
sortir de cette vision
introverti où on parle de l'islam tel
qu'une chose un dossier qu'on ne
connaîtrait pas donc si plus on gagne de
la distance plus on réduit la distance
et mieux en est donc le sim le simi il
est là pour créer du lien justement et
voir dans quelle mesure on pourrait se
dire a fait avancer faire avancer la
société française vers une condition
plus apaisé est ce que c'est
précisé en fait toutes les autres
grandes religions à dire donc les
catholiques où les juifs donc ont déjà
une instance donc deux dialogues donc là
c'est juste un manque en fait qui est
comblé par rapport à la halle à la
communauté entre guînes et musulmans
est-ce que la création aussi de ce
conseil doit permettre un meilleur
contrôle en tout cas prévenir la
radicalisation dont on parle assez
souvent parce que 7 buts est ce que vous
avez des consignes par rapport à ça
c'est un point qui interpelle tout le
monde aussi bien on va dire à vous
préoccuper aussi j'imagine à bâle qui
interpelle tout le monde
d'une part donc comme vous l'avez dit on
peut être on est citoyen mais on peut
être même en donc ce n'est pas
antinomique
et deuxième chose de voir donc des
jeunes qui se radicalise ça nous ça nous
émeut comme ça peut mettre donc on va
dire l'ensemble de la population
bon le simi n'a pas vocation on va dire
ne peut pas
se saisir et corriger tous les problèmes
mais il va y avoir une réflexion on va
donc parce qu'on est tous des gens de
terrain et nous allons essayer aussi
dans la mesure de notre possible parce
que c'est un phénomène quand même
nationale d'essayer d'apporter des
solutions à la mesure de nos moyens là
voilà quels sont vos moyens comment ça
va fonctionner justement ce conseil aura
des réunions mensuelles
je pense qu'il y aura des réunions mais
je veux dire avant cela il faut
s'attarder un peu sur la vision vous
avez parlé du phénomène de
radicalisation à quel moment ce
phénomène il va s'intensifier lorsque
les équilibres dans une société sont
rompues lorsqu il y à une panne de lien
aujourd'hui le simi avec d'autres
acteurs le simi n'est que dix ans une
première une première chose c'est à dire
c'est une expérience qui est intéressant
d'autant qu' il y a un amant 6 me donc
c'est à dire les expériences existent
c'est juste que le l'installation bien
donner bien propulser le simi lui donner
plus à dire de plus de force plus de
vigueur donc de manière à ce que nous
puissions parce que les gens qui croient
parce que il ya des expériences des
échanges des choses il ya un actif qui a
permis de d'installer le simon il n'a
pas été installé comme ça on va essayer
quelque chose donc les gens sont très
préoccupés les présidents associés je ne
suis tous les membres du simi le sont
donc des gens sont déjà très préoccupé
donc si nous donnons une priorité c'est
que nous avons foi à ce que le 6000
puisse assumer un rôle que notre que
l'on ne pourrait peut-être pas assumer
c'est à dire dans les dents l'état des
collectifs existants s'il ya des
collectifs qui existe il ya des gens qui
ont pensé à une certaine façon de vivre
ensemble
mais visiblement il n'est pas assez
suffisant par rapport comme je les dis
nous sommes passés de du besoin aux
devoirs ou devoir citoyen on va être
prêt par le temps dont je serai très
rapidement pour fermer cet entretien
vous allez avoir des moyens vous avez
des moyens dans le cadre de ce signe de
moi du moins de moyens sont
sans réclamer sont demandés normalement
il devrait venir parce que cela va
conditionner la suite donc la suite de
la chose de l'émission la réussite sa
condition de la marge et puis ce
partenariat il faut pas qu'ils soient
qu'ils accusent de défections dans tout
un chacun est responsable au niveau de
la responsabilité pour que pour que
cette chose là qui va servir c'est à
dire le vivre ensemble donc la vie du
quotidien du français donc il est
important que on le regarde avec
l'attention que cela suscite le mérite
notre dernière question nous sommes en
plein ramadan je voudrais juste vous
faire réagir sur la fin du ramadan la
mise en place d'un abattoir mobile sur
elancourt une nouvelle fois c'est
reconduit c'est suffisant ou ça fait
partie des problèmes aussi que vous
allez saisir
je sais jamais assez suffisant mais je
pense qu'il va répondre aux qui est un
peu plus loin d'ailleurs sur saint
germain l'abattoir mobile donc c'est
plutôt pour l'aïd el-kébir star dans
deux mois car au-delà de la fin du
ramadan mais quelques enfin will
abattoir mobile de nous sert nous à
saint germes moi même donc j'ai pu faire
l'aïd deux fois ici à elancourt crastes
abattoirs mais ce n'est pas suffisant et
donc il va falloir j'espère trouver
d'autres solutions avec et de dire
comment elle la préfecture
les maires des communes pour essayer
vraiment d'apaiser aussi de faciliter ce
rite qui est très important
les hybrides mans le 15 juin il ya eu
une rencontre une instance de dialogue
qui était installée au sein du ministère
de l'intérieur
et toutes ces questions du rituel ans et
ont été évoquées notamment les abattoirs
puis il ya des solutions qui mérite
d'être exploité où il ya des gens qui
ont déjà de bonnes expériences ça mérite
d'être méditée puis généralisé avec les
particularités de chaque département
mais ça s'est il faudra voir au cas par
cas et faire en sorte que la chose ne
viennent pas gêné au contraire vient à
plaisir apporté la solution inspirée
merci à tous les deux est revenu sur ce
plateau le conseil des institutions
musulmanes dans les yvelines est donc
lancée et c'est une première en france
elle dernier volet ce soir de notre
dossier consacré à l'europe nous nous
penchons sur les relations entretenues
par les citoyens avec l'institution face
à la chute de la participation aux
différents scrutins également face à la
montée des extrêmes le projet back to
school retour à l'école a vu le jour
il permet à des membres de la commission
européenne de rencontrer et des ailes
lycéens le reportage
jacques métais à présent directeur à la
commission européenne a fait ses études
au lycée allant du vésinet il est revenu
dans son ancien établissement avec un
objectif tout particulier ma motivation
c'est non pas d'essayer de vendre
l'europe je suis pas là comme un vendeur
je suis là pour communiquer c'est à dire
essayer de clarifier certains points
d'expliquer certaines choses mais aussi
pour écouter et je suis très très
désireux de savoir un petit peu ce que
la jeune génération pense et ce à quoi
elle aspire
je sais qu'il ya des anxiétés il ya des
aspirations il ya des problèmes se
posent des questions
il ya une certaine image l'europe je
leur ai dit que il y avait beaucoup de
choses utiles qui étaient en
construction
parfois ils étaient un peu surpris
parce qu'on a tendance parfois nous voir
que les problèmes mais en fait il ya des
choses très positives au niveau européen
je crois que ça les a un petit peu
rassurés de gamme quand on arrive à un
contrôle direct sur sa représentation
d'abord lorsque je les ai encouragés à
certaines choses comme la mobilité
je leur ai parlé un petit peu du
programme erasmus combien c'était une
valeur ajoutée dans leur cv d'aller voir
d'autres expériences d'autres modèles de
pensée apprendre d'autres langues et je
trouve ça vraiment bien parce que à voir
ce lien direct c'est ce qu'il ya
vraiment de mieux on parlera directement
et si j'avais un message de conclusion
serait de dire j'espère que je serai
invité encore pour pouvoir continuer la
conversation l'avenir sont les jeunes il
n'y a pas de mystère
aucune hésitation possible là dessus on
se rend pas compte tous les enjeux qu'il
ya derrière le fait qu'il ya 28 pays
donc ça montre qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de cultures qui sont très
différentes et c'est difficile de mettre
tout le monde d'accord
je trouve que c'est une très bonne
initiative de la part du lycée de la
commission européenne le sentiment
d'appartenance au statut de citoyen
européen était l'un des sujets de
discussion ce jour là je me sens
européen parce que j'ai grandi dans
l'union européenne et avec j'ai grandi
avec l'euro
donc c'est je vous dirais que je me sens
eu l'euro perd presque malgré moi parce
que on m'a pas vraiment enseigner ce que
c'est qu'être européen ce que c'est
l'union européenne donc c'est pas très
rationnel en fait il ya un travail
pédagogique à faire
donc ça passe notamment par des
conférences de ce genre là mais même
intégré parce que c'est l'union
européenne et faire comprendre aux
étudiants de même à partir d'un jeune
âge que finalement ces impacts leur vie
de tous les jours de manière visible
back to school une initiative lancée en
2007 par le gouvernement allemand
la france y participait pour la première
fois cette année et c'est un franc
succès près de 300 fonctionnaires y ont
pris part
fin de notre dossier europe pour cette
semaine 5426 diplômé de l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
retrouvé grâce à un jeu en ligne la
première saison de game of us qc son nom
s'est déroulée sur trois mois il doit
permettre à terme de recenser l'ensemble
des étudiants passés et diplômé par
l'établissement afin qu'ils
entretiennent la des relations et fasse
la promotion de la fondation ups q7
façon ludique de procéder fera son
retour à la rentrée de septembre
rendez vous demain c'est la fin de ce
journal pour une nouvelle édition nous
ferons le point sur l'actualité du jour
comme chaque vendredi également
l'essentiel de la semaine votre soirée
sur téléphiles c'est avec florane
parfait pour filer qu'aux bonnes soirées
donc à demain